Joel clap back here on the show how are
you Joel what's up how are you man what
was it like in the stadium yesterday I'm
satiric you know yeah you familiar with
the Chappelle show
of course right do you remember the line
from the Chappelle show
do you have hate in your heart let it
out right I mean like that's what this
feels like and I gotta tell you like I
love it I love it I love this sport
right I love college football and these
types of rivalries are what I love most
now some people don't like them and they
wanna you know they want squeaky squeaky
clean and they want handshakes and back
rubs after the game I this is what makes
it great candidly rich we don't have
this in professional sports anymore we
just don't
vitriol to this extent we don't have
Laker Celtics well I mean we don't
really even have this whole Red Sox
Yankees series this postseason I mean
did you feel anything like we felt when
Don Zimmer was getting thrown like this
awesome like I think we should
appreciate it and I don't I don't want
to take sides I think I can see both
people's arguments I was standing in the
booth when this happens okay so you know
how early you get there for a game and
I'm up there it's reading over a lot of
my notes and and I'm gonna go down to
the field a little bit later after all
the teams get there and Michigan State
comes out and and I can tell they're
like all lining up across the end zone
and I'm like oh this is you know this is
interesting I do that they did their
walk but I got a I got to tell you I
thought they were late as well just
based on on when they arrived it was
less than two hours from kick generally
buses arrive and and guys start coming
out to the field or first get to the
locker room about 2 hours and 15 2 hours
and 20 minutes before kick so when they
came out I thought candidly in my head I
was like how this is interesting is
they're late I saw some guys for
Michigan down on the field and I get
from up there I couldn't tell exactly
who they were so I get on the talk back
and I saw my director I'm like hey who
are those guys down there and so they
now all our camera guys start getting
position they started flying around and
zooming around and so we're in position
or sooner that we're gonna be he and
sure enough there's Devin Bush and we
had cameras all over it and you know the
Michigan guys are like hey like I'm not
moving and the Michigan State guys are
like well we're not gonna not break our
arms or whatever and so this there was
this altercation and it happens right in
front of Martin Antonio right right so
happened so how can how can you know
again obviously I have an emotional tie
to this thing but I'm more than happy to
call out you know or more than
professional to call out you know
Michigan if it's deserved but how can
Dantonio called the description be s if
if he I mean he literally was walking
past in between the two Michigan guys
one of whom was Bush when there was
something going on he was right there
yeah I think what he was calling I think
the way I read it is that he was is that
the the the insinuation was that he was
smiling and laughing at the altercation
and I think that's what he said was BS
but I mean I don't know what he was
smiling at he seemed to have a grin he
tends to have a wry smile I don't I
don't have a problem if he is smiling
over the fact that these kids are
getting after it and that they are
amidst a rivalry and he knows
something's getting stirred up I mean as
you pointed out this is what the rivalry
is about I mean but right but to not own
it then afterwards is a little bit
bizarre IIIi don't know what I look I
don't want to put you in a position
because you call these tank games and
you call them G speak I don't know what
he was I don't know what he was smiling
about
I mean candidly you know it's a little
easier for us to get a beat on and chat
with Mark Dantonio that it is Jim
Harbaugh's you know so I feel like I
know mark more than I know that
passionate guy right let me tell you
that I would have no problem sending my
son to play for either gentleman so
there you go like you know I think I was
tweeting out I don't mind if Mark if
Mark was laughing
great yeah I know I'm fine and he's a
hell of a coach I was tweeting out about
that the way that he wrapped up that
game against Penn State the way that
that game wrapped up where he decided to
boot it away defend get the ball back
and try and score and he still had a
timeout in his back pocket he didn't
even use it so really left him a timeout
he ran out about listen this guy's a
great coach and I'll defend him you know
as to any extent and listen but again
this is what I love about it this just
means that I prayer that we get this
game again next year and I thought it
was fantastic I I really did I the only
thing that I thought got a little out of
hand I thought that the officials were
way too close to the vest with all their
unsportsmanlike penalties candidly
I mean they were they were handing him
out like like Halloween candy and I
didn't think that was warranted having
said that you know they're gonna do what
they're gonna do I thought it was a
great game Michigan State was clearly
overmatched and and and out manned and
in large part due to the fact that they
had so many injuries
the injuries were decimating their their
football team and Michigan's not be
dealing with anywhere near the amount of
injuries that Michigan State is although
two of their better if not the best two
players on their team or not playing
Tarik Black was not back yet at wide
receiver and Rashad Gary was not playing
at defensive end so but I will I will
say and I know I'm going off in a little
different direction but rich go for it I
believe what I said during the broadcast
and I was speaking to Michigan fans I
think you guys have been waiting since
late 90s to hear that it's real and I
think it was kind of real two years ago
and you were in a position to maybe beat
Ohio State and go to the you know Big
Ten championship and that and then
compete for a playoff spot but this
feels different to me it feels more
well-rounded I feel like it's a better
team I feel like the weakest link of the
team right now is still quarterback play
and yet he's got a lot of room for
growth and there's a lot of potential
there because he's still a very skilled
player and Shea Patterson and that's
what this is real for Michigan I think
that they're absolutely the favorite in
the Big Ten I felt that before last week
I was saying that on several different
outlet
Ohio State proved me right because I saw
them two weeks ago they've got a lot of
holes and right now Michigan is the best
team of the Big Ten I think if they win
the conference with only one loss
they're gonna be in the college football
playoff I want to get to that in a
second Joel Claude here in the Rich
Eisen show what what what is wrong with
Ohio State well I mean how how did that
er day night develop based on what you
just said when you saw them a couple
weeks ago Joe yeah exactly how they have
been playing of late and and namely
there's only one thing that they're
doing as an elite level which is
throwing the football and you can't win
like that there's a reason as much as he
would bristle at this there's a reason
that Mike Leach has never even won his
own division rich there's a reason
because in this sport you still have to
be a complete team to win championships
whether that's the division championship
a conference championship or national
championship all these passing numbers
are all well and good they're all well
and good but what does it come down to
to beat Georgia to beat a team like
Alabama or Clemson or even Oklahoma what
you gotta do control the game on the
ground there's a reason Georgia beat
Oklahoma last last year so if that's the
only thing you can do you've got major
issues and right now Ohio State's not
playing quality defense they're losing
the rushing game battle on almost a game
and game out basis in particular yards
per rush they're giving up way too many
big plays in fact last week coming into
that game against Purdue they had given
up 22 plays of 30 or more yards which
was sixth worst in college football
their man coverage is not quite as good
on that defensive side and they cannot
run the ball that was their fourth
straight game the average under three
yards per carry that's a huge line of
demarcation just to give you a sense of
how important that three yards per carry
is Michigan under Jim Harbaugh is 34 and
oh when they averaged three yards or
more per carry during a game there oh
and 12 when they averaged under that 3
yards per carry per game so it is a
major major thing at Ohio State is not
doing it very well and the thing that is
alarming a lot of people is that their 5
offensive linemen would probably start
pretty much everywhere in the country
you know if you took
five offensive linemen there playing
against that Purdue and their five
offensive linemen you would take all
five of the Ohio State offensive linemen
well before you would take any five of
the Purdue offensive linemen and that's
why it's so alarming for people well
when you saw urban I mean Dan Patrick
had a chat with herb Street earlier and
is they echoed what a lot of people are
talking about that he doesn't look right
literally physically that whatever went
down with him and you know the inquiry
whatever might be Aling him to cause him
to take that medication that affects his
memory according to the inquiries
findings did you find urban okay
based on what mom's on him I felt like
there there was something there I think
that though you've week before we had
and remember he went down to a knee
middle of the game with that headache
and had to be attended to and you know
and and when I went in and saw them that
next week I saw him on Thursday said he
was doing okay that he's got to take you
know that the medication and he doesn't
like taking the medication when I saw
him on Friday
you know I it wasn't the same urban that
I meet with on a week in week out basis
well you know when I go in there on
Friday it just wasn't the same you could
you know when you can tell when
someone's sitting in front of you and
they've got something physically
bothering them there's some pain you
know and it's and I you could tell and
he even you know rub his head a couple
of times and and was squinting a little
bit more than I thought he was or than
he normally is so yeah I think that
there's some truth to that and certainly
Kirk you know knows that program and
knows him exceptionally well and and I
saw it the same as Kirk has a couple
more things left with Joe Clapp here on
the Rich Eisen show all right I'm gonna
hit you with what I kind of hot taked at
the second hour with LSU and an Auburn
Alabama playing each other why wouldn't
it benefit Alabama to lose this game
because that would take them maybe out
of an SEC Championship appearance
against either Georgia of Florida and
then they could one loss their way into
the Final Four cuz how are they going to
keep Alabama out of it seriously and the
fact that Michigan goes on this run like
you just witnessed and potentially let's
just as a big if beat Penn State beat
Ohio State
they got a face Wisconsin again I know
you've got that game so that there are
business interests in a little bit here
but I what are we doing here with these
yeah championship contests I agree
wholeheartedly with what your sentiment
is it has always been that that we
should reward only teams that win their
conference championship I thought that
this playoff in its creation was totally
undermined by the SEC in its creation
and quite frankly the rest of the
country had to yeah a little bit
bowed to the SEC because the SEC was not
going to agree to a playoff period they
weren't going to be involved rich unless
it was the four best versus the four
most deserving as soon as you say four
most deserving you can say that you have
to win your conference championship in
order to be considered by the playoff
committee that's the only fix that we
need in this whole thing that creates
much more value and importance last year
on the game like the Iron Bowl because
last year's Iron Bowl didn't matter at
all in fact it penalized Auburn because
they had to go and then play Georgia in
the game that ultimately meant nothing
Georgia how is that fair them should go
and play an extra game against a team
that already beats you to get yourself
into the playoff I felt that for a long
time two years ago and this is not just
an Alabama argument I argued that Penn
State should have gone ahead of Ohio
State because Ohio State didn't even win
their own division and they should not
have been involved in the playoffs so
the playoff is broken and in your
sentiment I believe you're right I don't
I don't think that they would keep
Alabama out of the playoff here's the
only thing that I would say is that
their strength of schedule outside of
this LSU game is really bad really bad
and there is some talk because remember
and you know God rest his soul Mike
Slive who's no longer with us and was a
terrific Commissioner he was the one
that pushed and pushed and pushed for
for most four best teams and now there's
there's more there's more momentum
there's more of kind of a backing for
the commissioners that are in the let's
say the Big Ten with Jim Delaney in the
big 12 with Bob Bowles being the pac-12
with Larry Scott where they are behind
closed doors
urging the committee to honor conference
championships even more so than they
were supposed to in the past remember
they were supposed to to allow a non
champion and they were supposed to be
unequivocally better and they've they've
very seriously toed that line with what
I think are some falsities in the last
couple of years I do think that we're
gonna get back to a point this year
where we're going to honor Conference
champions more than we will just teams
that we can say via the eye test that we
think they're the four best
oh we add four more make it eight and
it's an automatic bid for whoever wins
their conference championship games so a
team like Wisconsin still has a path to
make the national championship round and
those conference championship games
actually matter how about that Joel yeah
well I'm in the minority I don't like
that at all I think that's a really I
think that's the wrong way to go because
as soon as you have automatic bird then
all the sudden the non-conference means
absolutely nothing absolutely nothing so
those games are devalued to zero and
they're only valued in hindsight once
you have the two teams you're
considering or three teams that you're
considering for some sort of at-large
bid I don't want hindsight games
mattering I want games mattering on the
field when they're played so for me I
want to keep the playoff at one less
team that we have power conferences
because I do not want automatic entries
for anybody but I do want a
qualification a prerequisite if you will
that you have to win your conference in
order to be considered for one of the
four spots in the playoffs well I'm
going to reject your well thought out
unintended consequence and lock arms
with my thought and just go from one end
zone to the other and just steamroll
Joel how about that that's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna put my headphones on
great call with Gus as always Joel
thanks for the call you gotta thanks Joe
you bet Simeon Jets Joel class at Joel
clock on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience